lee min squeezed three lemons to make
lemonade
she squeezed 42 milliliters of lemon
juice from the first lemon
36 milliliters of juice from the second
lemon and 45 milliliters of juice from
the third lemon
how much lemon juice did lemon squeeze
from her three lemons
well we just have to add how many
milliliters she got from each of them
add them all together so from the first
one she got 42 milliliters
42 and for short for milliliters i could
write lowercase m for milli for milli
and then uppercase l for liters 42
milliliters from the first lemon 36
milliliters from the second lemon 36
milliliters and then 45 milliliters from
the third lemon 45 milliliters so we can
just add these three quantities together
so let's do that let's add them together
so we're gonna get something in terms of
milliliters so let's go first to the
ones place two plus six is eight eight
plus five is thirteen
thirteen is three ones and one ten so i
could write that one ten in the tens
place
so one plus four is five plus three is
eight plus four is twelve so it's going
to be twelve tens which is the same
thing as a hundred and twenty so in
total lehman squeezed 123 milliliters
from her three lemons let's do another
problem like this
sarah poured five cans of motor oil into
the container below so this container
below has 55 let's see this is halfway
it's filled up after she poured the the
five cans and it's filled up halfway
between 40 and 50. so this mark right
here
this looks like
that would be 45
so it's filled up to 45 milliliters so
she poured five cans and those five cans
combined ended up being 45 milliliters
all of the cans held the same amount of
oil and i guess we can assume that the
can that this that this that this this
container below was empty before she
filled any of the cans in so all the
cans held the same amount of oil how
many milliliters of motor oil were in
each can
so she had five cans so one
one can
two cans
three cans
four cans
and five cans they each had a certain
amount of oil in them they each had a
certain amount of oil in them
and when she put them all in so let's
say they each have a question mark of
oil in them so she had five cans and
they each had a question
mark amount say question mark
milliliters of oil in it
and when you
multiplied by five when you put all five
together you got 45 milliliters
you got 45 milliliters
so five times what amount of oil per can
would get us to 45 in total well 5 times
9 is 45.
so this thing right over here 5 times
5 times 9 is 45.
so sarah
sarah had 9 milliliters in each can they
each have the same amount they say that
all the cans held the same amount of oil
so if you had nine milliliters in each
one
notice in each if in each of the five
cans you had nine milliliters five times
nine is
45 so she had 49 milliliters of motor
oil in each can